[音楽]
私にはマレーシアに大切な人がいます
ボルネオ島の小さな村九路に住んでいます
トゥーロンに初めて行ったのは2001年
私が24歳の時
植林ツアーに参加したのがきっかけでした
その3日間のホームステイが私の人生を大きく変えました
私はそこから毎年のようにトゥーロンに通い続けています
初めてホームステイしたときその暮らしはとても貧しく見えました
水道がなく雨水をドラム缶に集めて生活しています
お風呂はボロボロの小屋のトイレの隅
ろうそくの明かりを頼りに体を洗っていると
大量の鉢が小屋いっぱいに富んでいるのが見えました
髪を怒らせないように静かに体を洗いました
ボルネオ島は何国ですが夜になれば冷たい風が吹いて水は悲鳴をあげたくなるほど
冷たく感じます
パパのフェリックスは私を気遣バケツ1杯分の水を端ためて用意してくれました
そのお湯の温かさは体中に済みました
当時パパには小さな子供が5人もいて外でボール遊びをしたり
画面へで水遊びや歌を一緒に歌いました
大人たちもギターを弾いたり太鼓代わりにバケツを叩いたり
私はまだ若かったのでボランティアといっても
旅行家分新しい服にしっかりメイク
でも子供達と汗だくになって市政の中で遊んでいたらだんだんノーメイクで着飾らない
方が自分らしい息がしてきました
トゥーロンの人たちの口癖は木田パパ
大丈夫という意味です
小さなことは気にせず何でも千田ぱぱーっと笑い飛ばしていました
私が思う貧しい国のイメージと違って九路のみんなはいつも明るく楽しそうです
賑やかなホームステイでした
あっという間に別れの日がきました
帰り際パパと悪勝するとその手の中にはお金が含まれていました
日本円にすれば数百円かもしれないけれど私は驚き
すぐにパパに返しました
同時に涙がブワッとあふれポロポロ泣き出す私をパパはただただ微笑んで見守ってい
ました
子どもたちは敗れたボロボロのシャツを着ているのにその服を1枚買うこともしないで
自分よりもきれいな服を着て裕福に暮らしている私に貴重なお金を差し出してくれた
ことが信じられませんでした
自分のことよりも私のことを優先する人に初めて出会いました
国際協力なって少しでも思っていた自分が恥ずかしくなるくらい
私を喜ばせてくれました
みんなの笑顔が見たくて
何度も里帰りするように一人で九路に行くようになりました
するとデューロのみんなもおかえりと言って私を迎えてくれるのです
村で仲良くなった少女は私に宝物の小さな鶏の卵をプレゼントしてくれました
彼女が大切にラッピングして飾っていたものです
私も何か贈りたくて何か欲しいものはない
と聞くと何もいらないあなたに出会えたことが最高のプレゼントだから普段から
分け合う気持ちが村にはあるんです
いつもするするっと金登ってはフルーツを取って食べさせてくれる子どもたち
一つしか撮れなかった時は自分たちが我慢をして私に食べさせようとしました
だから私も一口だけ食べて負けることにしました
人に与える喜び人にもらう喜び
それ以上に分け合うことが一番の喜びだと知ったから
そうやって7年が経った頃パパから手紙が届きました
ヒューロンでの仕事がなくなって出稼ぎに来ている家族と会えなくて寂しい
笑顔あふれる家族の姿が何より好きだったのでそのクラスがなくならないために
私にできることはないかと考えました
私をいつも家族の一人として受け入れてくれるみんなに恩を返したくて
ちょうどその時ある言葉を聞きハッとしました
無力と微力は違うそうか私は無力じゃないんだ
すぐに一人で募金活動を始めました
何をどうやったらうまくいくかまったくわからなかったけど何もやらないゼロよりは
マシだと募金箱を作っておいてくれる場所を探しました
より多くの人に知ってもらいたいと話せる場所を探しました
0よりましたと始めた募金は1年で100万円ほどになりました
見ず知らずの男性が自分はいけないから同2枚の棋譜をポンと出してくれたり小さな
子どもが握りしめて出してくれた10円玉
私が熱かったお金にはたくさんの人の思いが詰まっている
これを届けるまでは[ __ ]ない人生で初めて使命感を感じました
これだけたくさんの思いやる日本人がいることも
q 論のみんなに伝えたかった
植林ツアーでお世話になった団体の協力のおかげで
その募金で全世帯に青いプラスチックでできた
錆びない貯水タンクと
井戸を設置することができました
その時はもう一つ大事な報告を持ってきました
実は募金活動をきっかけに夫と出会い結婚が決まったんです
ずーっと結婚はまだかと聞いてきたパパに報告をするととても喜んでくれましたが
次の瞬間悲しい顔して
朝日はもうここに来なくなるんだねと言いました
私はそんなことないよ必ず雷鳴夫を連れてくるからといって翌年用途を連れて行きまし
た
私がみんなを喜ばせようとこっそりウェディングドレスをもできました
自分の晴れ姿を見せたかったからです
ドレスを着た私に朝日パーティするよと
当時数台しかなかった古い車に楽さんのリボンをつけて
私たち夫婦を迎えに来てくれました
会場はたくさんの花を飾り付けた
村に一つしかないボロボロの集会場
知らない間に結婚パーティーの準備をしてくれていたんです
それはどんな立派なリブ人や協会よりも最高で幸せな結婚式でした
子どもたちは並んで歌を歌ってくれました
出会った頃あんなに幼かった皆が成長し
祝ってくれる幸せ
この子たちの笑顔にどれだけの幸せをもらっただろう
この子たちの笑顔をずっと見てきたい守っていきたい
私の両親席には幸せそうに微笑むパパとママ
私はトゥーロンのみんなに恩返しがしたくて
募金活動を始めたけれど恩を返せたと満足できたことありませんでした
でもそんなパパとママの姿が見られた時ほんの少しだけど本を変えてたのかなと思い
ました
募金活動には批判もあったけど全く響きませんでした
私には皆がしてくれた結婚式のような体の芯から震えるような感動がいつも心の中に
あったからです
去年村の人たちが入ってくれました
あの時朝日がこの村のためにチャレンジしてくれたおかげで旧論が変わった
みんな朝日に感謝してると
でも私が九路を変えたんじゃない9論が私をこんなに情熱的に行動できる人に支えて
くれたんだ
なにより人を思いやれる気持ちが持てた
みんながお互いに分け合い支え合いクラストゥーロンではありがとう
で負かしどういたしましてを様々と言います
様は同じという意味様々で同じ同じ
お互いさまさまといっているようで大好きな言葉です
貧しさに対する同情から生まれた一時的な支援ではなくみんなの笑顔が見たいという
シンプルな思いがお互い様の関係を見続ける
そんな家族のようなつながりが広がれば世の中はもっと明るく笑顔になる
私はそう信じていますありがとうございました
[拍手]